Let's say we have a variant of the SAT problem called MAX-SAT
where instead of the question
does the boolean formula have a satisfying assignment
we'd rather like to know what is the maximum number of clauses
in a given boolean formula that can be satisfied?
Let's say we have an algorithm for deciding this,
or rather, approximating it, where first we simply assign
true or false randomly to all variables,
and we count the number of satisfied clauses with this assignment.
Then we invert the assignment of all variables, that is,
we flip true to false and false to true for every variable,
and finally, we count the number of satisfied clauses
with this new inverted assignment.
Now, my question to you is what is the approximation factor of this algorithm?
And please enter the number in this box below.